Hello, chào mừng các bạn đã quay trở lại
với kênh lập trình Full Stack. Trong
video ngày hôm nay mình sẽ mang cho các
bạn những thông tin mới nhất về
Antiavity 2.0, một bảng cập nhật trong
những ngày vừa qua của Google và được ra
mắt ở trong sự kiện [âm nhạc] thường năm
đó chính là Google IO 2026 ha các bạn
ha. Nó nằm trong một cái hệ sinh thái
của Google Antravity [âm nhạc] là
Antigravity 2.0. Thì Google giới thiệu
Antigravity 2.0 là một cái standalone
desktop desktop application có nghĩa là
một cái ứng dụng độc lập của desktop. Nó
tập trung vào phát triển một cái thứ gọi
là agent first. Đó các bạn là tất cả mọi
thứ mọi thứ được thiết kế đều dành riêng
cho agent để có thể chạy nhiều song song
nhiều con agent cùng một lúc để giải
quyết những cái những cái tas trên những
cái project độc lập. Đấy đây nó có giới
thiệu nè các bạn ha. Đấy thì cái UI của
nó nó không còn là một cái ID code nữa
và mình không thể viết code ở trên cái
standalone desktop application này. Đó
thì các bạn nhìn vào UI thì các bạn có
thể đoán được đây chính là UI của cái
thằng agent manager cũ ở trong cái ID cũ
đó các bạn. Thấy các bạn thấy không? Thì
ở đây agent first có nghĩa là sao? Nó sẽ
tập trung vào
>> [âm nhạc]
>> agent. Agent nó sẽ làm việc tất cả mọi
thứ mà các bạn không cần phải làm gì cả.
Lúc trước thì nó là một ID và nó có một
cái cửa sổ chat agent kế bên đó thì các
bạn có thể về vừa viết code vừa sửa code
vừa kêu [âm nhạc] agent from để mà làm
việc. Thì lúc này vì tất cả mọi thứ đều
tập trung cho agent nên là bạn sẽ không
cần phải viết code nữa và agent nó sẽ
làm tất cả mọi thứ dành cho bạn. Và ở
trong phiên bản này nó khác với cái
agent manager cũ đó chính là như
[âm nhạc] sau. Đấy, ở đây nó có thứ gọi
là dynamic sub agent mọi người. Nó có
một cái trung tâm đó ai nè. Aent của bạn
nó sẽ trở thành một cái trung tâm điều
khiển nó có thể la nè, monitor cũng như
là điều phối những cái hoạt động này. Ví
dụ như mình from cho nó là một cái câu
là explore the codebay using parallel
sub agent và explain [âm nhạc]
it to me in work through. Có nghĩa là
sao? mình nói là hãy à khám phá cái code
của mình bằng cách là chạy song song
nhiều cái con sub agent có nghĩa là sub
agent nghĩa là những cái con agent
[âm nhạc] con đó các bạn và à giải thích
cho mình ở trong một cái tài liệu work
through. Vậy thì ở đây nó sẽ bắt đầu
chạy ba cái con AI agent. Các bạn thấy
không? Hay gọi là ba sub agent. Đầu tiên
là một cái con để mà research về
database. Một con research về API
midware, một con research về cái cách
khởi động foot trap cũng như là những
cái [âm nhạc] những cái định nghĩa. Đấy
thì ba con này nó sẽ cùng nhau làm việc
song song để mà giải quyết những cái vấn
đề phức tạp để tăng cái tốc độ ờ tăng
cái tốc độ làm việc đó các bạn. Đấy các
bạn có thể thấy nó giới thiệu ở đây. Đó
và cuối cùng ba con này nó làm việc xong
và nó sẽ tổng hợp kết quả và nó đưa ra
một cái gì? Một cái work through đó. một
cái artifact. Rồi ngoài ra đó các bạn
thì nó cũng có giới thiệu cho mình một
cái tính năng mới đó chính là scedule
tab à có nghĩ là lên lịch đó các bạn.
Các bạn có thể nhờ cái dùng cái con AON
của mình để mà lên một số các bạn sẽ
cung cấp cho nó một cái workflow nha. Ví
dụ như workflow về build, về test, về
deploy một cái application à và à mình
có thể lình lịch cho nó để mà nó làm
thay mình à trong những cái lúc mà mình
offline. Đấy. Đây các bạn thấy không?
Ví dụ như những cái lúc mà mình không có
online, ví dụ đúng cái giờ đó, 6:00
chiều đó thì mày [âm nhạc] phải deloy
lên production để làm gì? Để client họ
test. Đó, ví dụ như vậy ha các bạn ha.
Đó, mình đâu thể lúc nào cũng trực đúng
6:00 tối rồi mình bấm deploy rồi mình
triển khai tính năng mới n được đúng
không các bạn? Đó, thì đó chính là những
cái thứ mà nó mới ra mắt của antiravity
2.0. Ngoài ra đó các bạn thì nó vẫn giữ
lại cái bảng ID thôi các bạn. Nó chia
làm hai cái application rin nha các bạn
ha. Và ở trong cái ID thì nó sẽ không
còn cái UI của agent manager nữa. Và
mình thấy là trong cái thời buổi hiện
nay một cái dân file coding chính hiệu
thì họ thường là sử dụng cái giao diện
này, giao diện mà tập trung vào agent
gọi là agent first đó các bạn ha. Chứ họ
không có xài một cái ID vừa code, vừa
code vừa chỉnh sửa code vừa vừa from đâu
các bạn. Ví dụ như các bạn làm việc trên
nhiều dự án đi hoặc là một dự án các bạn
quản lý và chạy nhiều cái con agent đi
thì làm việc trên này thì hiệu quả hơn
chứ các bạn. Các bạn cùng chên vào
project thì các bạn cũng có thể biết
được là ừ hiện tại đang có bao nhiêu con
agent chạy song song và đã làm việc xong
chưa. Còn nếu như cái idea cũ thì các
bạn chỉ có một cái cửa sổ agent thôi thì
các bạn đâu có thể nào làm việc song
song được đúng không các bạn? Bạn không
thể nào chạy nhiều con nhiều con agent
song song được mà các bạn phải bắt buộc
phải làm việc ở trên cái antiravity 2.0
này. Đấy thì mình có biết một cái thằng
mà startup mới ra mắt gọi là gì ta?
Prit prism đó mọi người. Prit đấy. Prit
my thì nó cũng build một cái thứ gọi là
agent first đó mọi người. Cái nó sẽ tập
trung vào cái thứ gọi là
ờ đây frace đó. mình giới thiệu cho mọi
người đó nó sẽ tập trung vào đầu tiên nó
không có một cái cửa sổ để mình visualiz
code hoặc là những cái project structure
mà nó sẽ chỉ có những gì những cái
[âm nhạc] những cái terminal này, những
cái workspace nè hiển thị ở đây và một
số những cái cửa sổ để review khi mà
chạy [âm nhạc] những cái những cái web
đó hoặc là hoặc là view những cái
artifact đấy ha các bạn ha. Đấy ok đó là
cái tương lai là cái hiện đại ha các bạn
ha. Các bác bắt buộc phải à học hỏi cũng
như là thay đổi thôi. Rồi
video hôm nay cũng khá là dài rồi. Hẹn
gặp các bạn ở trong những cái video tiếp
theo của kênh lập trình fullstack. Các
bạn hãy like cũng như là comment ở trong
video này để mình có thêm nhiều động lực
để mà làm những cái video tiếp theo.
Chào tạm biệt các bạn. Bye bye.